العمليه التعليميه تعاني هذا لسان حال
المدارس في السودان
هنا في ولايه الخرطوم بدا الطلاب جلسات
الامتحانات روميسرا للجنه المعلمين
بمواصله الاضراب الا ان بعض المعلمين
قرروا مساعده التلاميذ دون المساس
بمطالبهم الان
نزلنا المدارس مع ابنائنا لانه المدارس
اصبحوا التلاميذ اصبحوا كالاتامى يمشوا
راجعين يمشوا راجعين وقفنا معاهم نزلتين
الامتحانات امتحاناهم وما زلنا على رابدين
على الجمر على حقنا يعني ما متنازين
معاناه الاباء والامهات ليست منحصره في
تزعزع العام الدراسي فقط بل امتدت لقيامهم
بدوري المعلم في التدريس والمراجعه لا
يمكن
تقفل المدرسه انت بتطالب بحقوقك بطرق
شرقيه لكن كونه المدرسه تقفل الضرر اكبر
ربما انه العام يتضرر والتعليم ده اهم
حاجه في اي دوله تقدم الرقيه والتطور كله
على التعليم العام
رغم الابتسامه التي تبدو على وجوه هؤلاء
التلاميذ الا انهم المتضرر الاول من اضراب
ينفذه عدد من المعلمين اضراب قد يسبب فشل
او ضياع العام الدراسي
لجنه المعلمين السودانيه تقول ان تعليق
العام الدراسي ليس في مصلحه احد لكنهم
حريصون على حقوقهم ولن يتراجعوا عن
مطالبهم تعطيل العام الدراسي كارثه
ماديين يدينا والله بيضاء
لحكومه الامر الواقعي دي والله ما يدينا
عشان ننقذ العمل الدراسي ده لكن والله
كمان
اه يعني يعني نحن مشينا خطوه تجاهك تعال
خطوات تجاهنا عشان نقدر نقدر عمل دراسه
المخاوف لا تزال قائمه من انهيار التفاهم
بين لجنه المعلمين والسلطات المعنيه في
الدوله حاله اخفاق الاخيره في تلبيه
المطالب التي تم الاتفاق عليها ما يجعل
مستقبل التلاميذ محاطا بمخاطر لا يملكون
ردها سالم الهاشمي العربيه الخرطوم